his hands were once used for battle  now they're about humble tools for peace  i need to figure out  exactly who i am  [Music]  and also we've been given a new look at  the film with natalie portman's jane  foster as mighty for chris hamworth as  for himself costumes are looking great  here especially jane foster her outfit  is looking really really good here  taikawatini goes on to say in an  interview that they're going to go on an  adventure together so it looks like  we'll be seeing some good action between  the two as a duo anyway that wraps up  this video so what do you guys think of  the outfits let me know in the comment  section below